this episode brought to you by
expressvpn the best VPN there is take
back your online privacy today
[Music]
you know I'm really gonna miss this
place so many pleasant memories really
well when he didn't cover us in blood
that one time no I know this is an
adjustment but at the same time we've
grown too big for this place and he
responds a lot bigger we're gonna start
off the new year with brand new ways of
torturing you
yeah oh by the way do you think we'll
have time to watch that Christmas
special tonight or at the very least
that one sing of course we wouldn't miss
that we're just gonna watch at the new
location
[Music]
oh I'm sorry Walter heavy I am this is
Rachel she used to work with us the
moment is fast okay so what brought you
back to Chicago well I learned so much
in California about movies storytelling
restraining orders and I wanted to come
back here and see if you guys wanted to
help me shoot my special project yeah
what's it I wanted to do my
interpretation of a Christmas classic
home alone really I feel like there are
so many new directions you can take a
story like that but Hollywood doesn't
understand my vision that's so like them
everything has to be the same so I
wanted to see if you guys wanted to help
me make it sure we don't have to be out
here till the end December I gives us
plenty of time to share so wonderful now
I have to warn you my ideas can be a
little unconventional
we welcome unconventional around here
whatever you have in mind we are totally
with you
and action oh no my name is Kevin
McCallister and my house is being robbed
by a Satanist and a skinhead California
due to her
[Music]
Merry Christmas little fellow we know
that you're in there and that you're all
alone and you haven't accepted sickness
your Lord and Savior cut cut what is it
darling I'm sorry I know we're supposed
to be evil bar we've always supposed to
be this evil it's to go that extra step
to make you even more evil but I feel
like the criminals in the original we're
evil enough this just seems like
overkill we know this shootout at the
end is overkill this is just breaking
and entering but don't you feel dirty
filming this I'll tell you what critic
I'll have you watched the movie that
inspired me for all of this Nutcracker
in 3d what does it have Nazis in it yes
directed by world-renowned Andrei
Konchalovsky creator of critically
acclaimed art house films like the
runaway train the steamroller and the
violin and tango and cash I don't think
okay you spent years trying to get this
dream project off the ground
he wrote it directed it and managed to
get ninety million dollars to bring it
to the big screen
how much did it that's not important
what's important is this artist got his
vision on the screen artists are
constantly misunderstood when they use
anything shocking but it helps disrupt
the system and fight social norms oh I'm
sorry
weird from the other side of this door
it sounded like you said not Susan the
Nutcracker well let the critic go watch
the film so he can figure out what I'm
going for
well I film another scene with you two
Oh what about the Christmas special
we'll still watch it tonight just do
whatever she says come on we're gonna go
do the black mass where you're both
drenched in blood we're just talking
about this oh well let's see what kind
of dental work that mouth of madness has
this is Nutcracker in 3d Tori I start
out on a confusing note it's advertised
everywhere is Nutcracker in 3d but in
the intro it's called Nutcracker the
untold story
yeah it's untold for the same reason
grandpa story about shitting a
leprechaun is untold it's insane and
scares everyone so in 1920s Vienna that
curious time when orchestras took the
trolley to work a young girl named Mary
played by Ella Fanning is annoyed when
her younger brother max burns one of the
ornaments just to check we're going with
that take we're going with that take all
right yes dear
now we can't wait any longer so their
British father is going out with their
American mother while they wait for
their German uncle Albert Einstein in
Vienna he's played by Nathan Lane such a
beautiful city don't you see I have the
strangest feeling as if we are being
followed
mr. Lane under the impression that this
is a documentary we are not being
followed now I'm a little disappointed
if you think he's like the all-knowing
there Reiter who constantly breaks the
fourth wall he only briefly addressed
the audience two other times in the
middle of the movie and it always comes
out of nowhere it's so brief and lacking
can
Sisseton see it's kind of amazing it's
like starting off How the Grinch Stole
Christmas with every who down in
who-ville loved Christmas a lot by I
thought it was Halloween I came dressed
as Don King would you want a boss
it looks like Uncle Albert has a gift
for the kids
whoa hereditary doll house who's the fat
guy stink it's very sensitive about his
fate he kills anyone who brings it up
you're actually kid number five - on him
speaking of deathly horrors I called him
emcee for shows with tell initials they
say don't look at him too long he eats
hearts like creamed corn
what is just a toy for you maybe a real
friend for someone else my wife has a
toy that she calls the greatest friend
in the world and I hate it and no joke
he puts lyrics to the Nutcracker music
to instruct them about the theory of
relativity because I'm sure that was
jerk off skis idea when he wrote it
[Music]
originally I thought operas and bagels
were the worst things to have Einstein's
name on it thank you for proving me
wrong this is that these Souls fought to
smooth cuts I neared what adorable
spasms they're having I'm sure that's
protocol for hearing this on you tell us
the Nutcracker story
he does that hey if I uh Sam I'd flee
before having to watch what's up next
you Katie
what do you mean I mean I've been
waiting for someone who believed like
you you're really special I'm noticing
there's no enchanting music when this
horrifying thing comes to life but maybe
that's because the composer wrote
something like this
[Music]
call me MC or soul stabber destroyer of
good dreams
the maid hears them and comes up to see
what's happening I was fast asleep
dreaming and my pillows well just they
exploded god I didn't think you can make
pad maze acting look like Judi Dench but
the evidence stands before you yeah he
would have dropped dead if she saw me
anybody would you're like Terrance and
Phillip if they were Satan's dildos I
have to speak to my friends and adults
wait I have to get dressed first I don't
have time how ungrateful men can be
really no take two on that okay okay you
might find it a little changed are you
ready I'm not ready for anything with
your creepy face staring at me I ain't
Lasseter when he was looking he tasted
like love
so they find the house has changed and
everything has become a lot bigger and
even the toy I seem to have come to life
this house hasn't been refurbished
thirty-year yeah no I just I was getting
one of my bike races the time that I was
reduced to this you know I can't believe
I'm saying this for the second time in
the 11 years I've done this show Care
Bears was more faithful than this why do
they call you your highness no reason
just something they do because I'm the
king of pissed pants when I'm on screen
you should see the movie theater floors
Mary you're very pretty
I thank you I thought about wearing your
face as a hat is that too forward they
go up the tree to see the Snow Fairy
played by the same woman who played the
mother I want to thank your friend Mary
here for my wonderful new gown it burned
quite conveniently those sins some
delicate parts she sees the dance of the
dandruff and the fairy says that she can
join them but I can't fly how do you
know if you've never tried get on with
it
go on
[Music]
you know so this is what the woman from
the omen saw before she jumped get on
with it
go on
[Music]
it's all for you
and once again they try putting lyrics
to the ballet music and it flows about
as well as you'd expect each day a new
beginning have you got a fight with
Manny you can guess yes and yes for your
special and unique
critic I need to borrow you for a
musical number one second we will get
you Kevin we will send you to heaven I'm
sorry was this really written to have
lyrics what does it matter I feel like
the composer might have constructed it
to match a little bit better no it's
fine for the opening music credits I
just put in the lyrics from the first
song in Nightmare Before Christmas this
is Halloween this is Halloween hey that
does match so you agree it's a good idea
wonderful I think I got what I need from
you here continue watching that
brilliant version of Nutcracker you
don't want this alright who's ready for
the cannibal scene do we actually bite
off fingers in this well not fingers
somehow through love or some shit the
Nutcracker turns into Timmy from
Jurassic Park I'm going straight back to
my king the least you could do is ask
her for a dance
we just started dollar store at kadhai
nice
our goal is to be as forgettable its
Nutcracker and the four realms admit it
you forgot that was even a thing they
dance and they go further up the tree to
explain how the Rat King took over his
kingdom he released his army into the
city center but Nutcracker everybody
giant metal schlongs that hold rat
people there somehow still less scary
than the Foos these flowers will stop
them please notice my flower attack
don't cut away from me
the Rat King is frightened of the Sun
yeah I guess these are the Nazis
everyone talks about in this film and
I'll tell you the gut Art Spiegelman's
work completely backwards it's the cats
who are supposed to be the Nazis nothing
mice gather was the most serious Tommy
Jerry comic ever read the Rat King is
played by John Turturro portraying a
Hitler type Andy Warhol don't you mean
similar to there is absolutely nothing
similar to this as the soldiers
discovered saboteurs trying to blow up
his base you'll never be more than a
mangy dirty rat it's all so unnecessary
how about a magic trick
Oh wasn't that magical god this is so
Tchaikovsky you know it's good that kids
can watch this and think Nazis aren't
all that bad I do hope this has a tie-in
with Nick juniors upcoming show Nazi
Nazis I hear they're doing a crossover
with Peppa Pig see if you get this he
has a giant shark in a tank just so he
can kill it I'm not a villainous
mastermind but I feel like there's more
possibilities with a Hitler Andy Warhol
rat and a shark in a tank like something
more have to come out of that equation
hey look it's pictures of the audience
he just rubbed the kid's nipple
Nutcracker oh it's only you for pretty
much no reason at all there's also a
wreck we played by Francis de Latour no
I don't know I still think that's tonya
harding's mother spell on the prince is
broken he's alive and I can't imagine
test audiences actively writing down
more rat Queen legs open please lots not
entirely gone yet
it's funny so many horror films try to
scare people and don't succeed but
really all we needed was Andrei
Konchalovsky to entertain your kids that
somehow gets the most terrifying imagery
one could come up with his take on
Cartoon Network would be the most
terrifying thing imaginable next to
Cartoon Network the Red Queen recast her
spell to transform the Nutcracker back
to the way he was this somehow wakes
Mary up showing this was all a dream
question mark well she said why aren't
you in bed so only about halfway through
we suddenly get what's usually reserved
for the third act of Mary being told her
stories aren't true and nobody believing
her
what are you going nobody's something
your acting coach said a lot your
singing coach too to her credit I win
sing well if I had to stare at that
pac-man food udall either
[Music]
Oh where's my Rudolf when you neither
okay I can't go that far
Hey look the second time Einstein talks
to the camera I have the strangest
feeling that something is wrong at
Maggie's house you look like that troll
doll nobody played with at the bottom of
the toy chest
this thought would have bombed if they
all looked like you is everything all
right uncle a quiet word of my study
Albert comes to the house and finds
everything is in disarray when you leave
please will you take the dolls hearse
away with you tell me one scene before I
go Joseph were you blackmailed to be in
this movie - has it really been so long
since you've been a child how he cried
his dreams had done it so young father
get and all too soon his life was over
take yeah let's just call this song what
it is make-believe feel bombs gonna bomb
[Music]
it's one of those magical songs where
everyone remains perfectly still the
camera doesn't move and we're not even
focusing on the person singing it's like
step in time if it was sit in silence
yeah I saved it Philippe the father
agrees to let Mary keep the Nutcracker
when Albert shows he still has the peple
he played with when he was a kid
not realizing he was just one of the
many lucky pebbles Albert carries along
I'm so glad that leaves a house without
my lucky pebble meanwhile some rats
sneak into the house God you gotta love
those effects looks like emo Philips if
he was a secret of NIMH Happy Meal toy
as we cut through yes bye nothing well
you know Pumpkinhead would be a much
scarier movie if you look like that
[Music]
max wakes up and realize why he had
trouble sleeping that night and every
following night in the future do you
want to join in a fight against the Rat
King yes on one condition that you
promise not to break any more toys oh I
just looking at you is breaking ice they
head downstairs and find that the Rat
King has kidnapped everybody and asked
Miriam max to join him play something
for the kiddies drummer boy something
now
let's say you're unfortunate enough to
watch this as a child you don't know
what Nazis are World War 2 or anything
like that you'd probably be getting
through this movie okay
only bothered by the demon eyes of
Pinocchio Captain Crunch era but imagine
you're a kid halfway through and you see
this
Wow
you probably shit all over the floor
like I just did what's that smell again
that's the second time someone's done
this in this production
[Applause]
you
[Music]
as you hear all the time it's very easy
to steal someone's online information I
should know I stole my own identity last
week anyway you can be really protected
though with expressvpn protecting your
online information now is more important
than ever and without a VPN your
internet browsing data can be tracked by
your ISP cellular provider and companies
and of course hackers but when you use a
VPN your public IP address is masked so
even the websites you visit won't be
able to identify you you can feel safe
knowing that only that VPNs encrypt your
internet data but that expressvpn has
the fastest speeds they have server
locations and over 94 countries giving
you plenty of options to choose from
24/7 customer support whenever you need
it and apps for every device Windows iOS
Android Mac Linux router and more I use
it on my phone here you connect with
just one click
it's internet without restrictions
there's no activity or connection logs
your data is your business
having the best-in-class encryption 256
bit AES and being the market leading VPN
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar and the best part
is it's only $7 a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee I want Lee
information protected and I'm sure you
do too and this is the best one to do it
with take back your internet privacy
today and see how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box expressvpn dot-com
slash nostalgia critic that's expr ESS
VPN dot-com slash nostalgia critic for
three months free with a one-year
package take back your privacy today
visit expressvpn consolation nostalgia
critic to learn more protect yourself
from those who wish to do you harm even
if it's yourself
this was a very abstract ad
[Music]
you
so the Rat King takes Mary's friends
away and she tries to tell on them
father you can't even convince the man
we're real
we're like manbearpig wait is he real
now I keep losing track of what I'm
supposed to think you even have a
special rat buying for you to ride a rat
bye I'll be right back Mary I've been
easily seduced by fascism tell me do you
also have Turkish Delight
so Mary tries to figure out what to do
by talking to the monkey who for some
reason they just left behind do that
remember what your Uncle Albert
used to say when in doubt blow it up
that which seems young rich may in fact
be close at hand no I'm pretty sure was
when in doubt blow it up they travel
through the mirror to the Nutcracker
City and I have to say this Planet of
the Apes spin-off is much stranger than
I thought it would be the Sun is blocked
out by smoke from burning toys you do
know the rats burn toys wait like
inanimate toys or living toys like the
ones we've been seeing oh don't I
okay I guess that's supposed to mean
they're all live you're not you have a
wonder what happens to a dolls soul and
it then you're seriously not oh yeah you
thought this was just gonna be simple
bad guy Nazi imagery like in Indiana
Jones or old Looney Tunes cartoons but
no people being rounded up children
crying and the sky filled with smoke
from factories burning piles of what
they just made clear are living
individuals all of this is actually
happening
but it's cool because an incredibly
silly song is sung over it
that you lighten up the constant
reminder of one of the darkest times in
our worlds history
[Applause]
[Music]
you go home it moaning Lisa no you know
it's funny that Nathan Lane is in this
because this whole entire movie is like
the show the producers were trying to
put on to get it so jaw-droppingly awful
that it would bomb the first night
[Music]
[Applause]
I
come on let's get out of here before
they kill us I'm sorry but this is
disgusting this is legitimately
disgusting it makes me sick to my
stomach and the idea that other artists
would be inspired by this like other
people would want to replicate it it's
just so I got talked to Rachel for us
like I'm sorry I'll be right back
all right Kevin you out to wit my
friends Jeffrey Dahmer and John Wayne
Gacy pilgrim but there's no way you can
escape the biggest threat of them all
Charles Manson Kevin come on out or
we're gonna do terrible things to your
Legos
[Music]
pilgrim oh my god thank Christ
oh geez what is it now critic you mean
what is it now critic you're
serial-killing home alone it's not
actually serial killing it's just Lego
it's very clear what you're doing and
nobody's gonna think about a little kid
I'll winning burglars I'm just gonna
think about all the terrible things
those killers did critic I'm trying to
take people into the darkest region so
that the happy scenes seem happier I am
an artist I must be allowed to art but
it's coming across less like you wanna
make people feel good and more like you
just want to stand out by using shock
tactics oh that's rich coming from the
guy who gets people to watch him just by
shouting the f-word hey I don't just
shop I don't just shout the f-word talk
about me being immature nobody would
watch you if you didn't drop the f-bomb
all the time you know what you're insane
this projects insane and I'm gonna
finish this Nutcracker to prove that
it's insane - oh he just doesn't get it
it's always more important to be loud
than to be right you're on Twitter
aren't you oh I'm more than just
screaming the f-word aren't I so the
others escape but the Nutcracker is
about to be burned again I'm not
thinking of anything else okay get back
on track so they tried to distract the
guards while Mary saves it
[Music]
I'm starting to wonder if Jerry Lewis
just put on a fat suit and this was an
expensive Redux of the day the clown
cried I can see now why he never wanted
it released mary rescues the Nutcracker
wait that can't be him he's actually
there but the rat queen spell seems to
have worked too well and he's just an
inanimate toy please oh she just
realized she can't get out of her
contract but the fairy comes and says
only mary has the power to bring him
back it has to be you what do I have to
do I don't know buy the less than a day
I've known you has taught me all about
what love really is it seems to work
though as he's turned back into a real
boy
you're at life
you did it this inspires the workers to
rebel and the rack king and queen decide
to flee Wow that didn't take much
abandon the sinking what and in my
kingdom over some spoiled Brett knew the
fact that a casting director might
actually see when this is the reason to
go oh oh oh go big shit
so now there's rocket-powered nazi rats
how did no ballet ever work that in and
mary is locked in the elevator to
protect her doing a bang-up job as you
can see the kidnap her as they take her
brother aboard a helicopter to fly away
try now you said you could fly this
thing I know I can I just don't know how
to take off the essential fixing the
helicopter scene how did you con Sookie
forget to write for that
that's the Dumber games are happening
outside the rat king and queen try to
fly away but the Prince tries to stop
them
[Music]
Robotnik's designs were surprisingly
effective
please don't do that
the copter crashes and the day seems to
be saved I'm still thinking about what
Nazis did assholes what we finally see
our villains for what they really are
brats does a twist technically count if
there's no twist in it at all
[Applause]
Wow they're even putting lyrics to this
these jokers would put lyrics to four
minutes and 33 seconds of they had a
chance I'm sorry Mary but it's time for
you to go home this is my home no this
is only a dream darling do you think any
person would consciously come up with
all this shit guys I'm afraid not
your parents will miss you terribly in
that they're really terrible at missing
you she returns home where she had the
most strangest dream and you were awful
in it
and you and you and you I hope you don't
mind but I brought someone or not I
would like you to be it's my new
neighbor
Nicholas trout they call me and see the
shoot he's really good at cracking nuts
that was a via thing to say could I have
my father's magic pebble again great
read kid my father's magic pebble
oh I never liked pebbles it reminds me
of sand it's so coarse rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere you
were made for me you can tell by your
rush of emotion
something end up skating and I guess
living happily ever after
it's knife and really the grand a shot
to end on it's kind of dull Lord I mean
I've heard about being tone deaf but
this is taste death I can't believe how
awful this was it actually is hard to
conceive how much to pity and bad taste
it has it doesn't at all understand what
the Nutcracker is about or even what
Christmas is about it 100% ignores all
the important things they stand for like
peace and spreading joy and forgiveness
and excuse me I gotta talk to Rachel
well Kevin I'm just glad after
everything you've been through we can
come together as one happy family with
your brother Ted Bundy your sister
Lizzie Borden and me the killer
Shirley's the wrong plate and monster
cut the final shot thank you guys so
much for making my vision of home alone
finally come true well thanks for
putting us in it whatever it was okay do
you guys want to hang I just have to
edit this final scene that it'll be
uploaded oh thanks but we're actually
gonna go watch a Christmas special at
the new studio so so yourself
thank you again oh great
sorry I assumed you didn't want to be in
the rest of the movie no no I'm the one
that's sorry I mistook what you were
making for who you really are and I know
that's not true you're a good person and
a good friend and I'm sure you mean well
by all of this thank you that's really
nice of you to say with that said I
really don't know if it's a good idea to
post this I think people are gonna
misunderstand late it's already up
already yeah time moves faster on the
Internet there's already a bunch of
reviews for it it's just you're really
talented Rachel and I feel like you can
add a lot more substance than just shock
value critic we talked about this being
shocking and defiant is that the center
of what we do
I put psychotic killers in my kids
movies and you say the F word while
reviewing kids movie that's not the only
reason people watch they watch for a lot
more than that so yeah prove it
go one year on the nostalgia critic
without relying on the F word all right
oh well terrific
fine I already did
yeah I just realized I already did this
whole year I never said the F word in
any of the new nostalgia critic and
people kept watching well that's not
true there was that one time well what
about that time
but what does that mean then it means
shock is nothing without some form of
intelligence behind it and that's what
draws everyone in well I'm not trying to
draw everyone in just those gifted few
who can see how unique I am you know in
trying to be unique instead of yourself
you might be like everyone else trying
to do the same no that's alright alright
well we're going to be at the new
location watching your Christmas special
you're welcome to join us if you want
huh oh yeah I'll be there soon let's
take I got a lot of problems with this
serial killer version of home alone I
just watched I can't believe they did
this to home alone this is ridiculous
this movie was the equivalent of being
kicked in the gooc like not even with
like a soft rounded toe Nike this was
the equivalent of being kicked right in
the Twain I can't even a week of
explosive diarrhea would be more
entertaining this is the worst thing
I've ever seen and I was in the room
imagine building a Christmas tree out of
a cactus that was stuffed with
asbestosis and hornik I feel like I'm
having a reverse Grinch heart moment
here this movie is so bad it makes Rap
City Street kids look like Toy Story I'm
not really sure when I just watched
right now but I'm a little scared
I've seen some bad shit in my day I see
some bad movies but this this is sick
not everything has to be dark this isn't
a DC movie that was the worst that was
the opposite of good I'm along with
serial killers they say it's one of the
worst things that I've ever seen in my
life
this is just out there man that's it I
just I thought I'd seen everything and
you can't scare John Wayne Gacy away if
you put sharp objects on the ground that
he steps on it's just gonna make a more
mad not to mention you remaking home
alone you don't have a cameo from Akali
Culkin playing his character from the
good son that's just a missed
opportunity
I thought the Nazis in Nutcracker 3d
were bad but this just takes the cake if
you write this to paper are you
committing a crime I think you are I
think you actually should take this
person and give them a longer sentence
than any of the serial killers a star in
this room hey Tamra if you've never seen
this movie
don't Merry Christmas you filthy animal
but I don't get it but some people like
Nutcracker 3d didn't they
Oh
Wow
[Music]
hey where are you guys okay almost gonna
set up it's okay there's no rush
hey did I hear that right you haven't
said the F word in a year yeah I guess I
did they're gonna keep that up fuck no
that's good to know I don't need to rely
on it all right we're all set now right
we ready to get this baby going they
hated it no one liked my version of home
alone dad I just found out no one even
liked that version of the Nutcracker
I just wanted to dive into the dark
moment so that the happy moment seemed
all the more important but you didn't
understand the happy moments you didn't
even really understand the dark ones
Nutcracker in 3d is the same thing shock
value is fine if the purpose outweighs
the offense it's supposed to provoke
giving way to a positive idea or even
make people feel better by laughing at
how shocking it is but it takes a lot of
thought and a lot of skill to pull off
correctly when you focus too much on the
negative without really exploring or
understanding it you get something that
makes people not only feel Dumber but
kind of dirty the intent to bring
something positive gets lost in the need
to make yourself feel important but
honestly the same can be said for being
too positive - that can come across as
mockingly condescending somewhere in
between there's a balance that's tricky
to hold but can still be accomplished
but how will I know what negative things
and what positive things to focus on I
don't know it's different for everyone
yeah people go through different
experiences so they're inspired by
different things and even those things
change people ideas even places just do
your best and try to get inspired by
those who understand it better than you
speaking of which you want to see what
inspires us
oh no no I've already put you guys
through enough already you watch this
every year on our own this is the first
year we're finally watching it all
together speaking of which who's down
for just skipping the special and going
to the best part yeah you got it
everybody and mom there's a lot of
people out there who don't associate
Christmas with the best stuff maybe
they're spending it alone or maybe they
associated with a bad time what can you
say to people out there who are not
having such a good Christmas uh you know
this is the time of year to reach out to
someone else who's lonely or is having a
hard time and do something nice for them
because when you do that you'll feel
less lonely inside of yourself as well
it's a perfect time of year to do
something for somebody else and think of
others that's really nice mom thanks so
much Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
let's watch it again
[Music]
click what I have my father's magic
pebble
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
Oxfam America Oxfam is a global
organization working to end the
injustice of poverty they help people
build better futures for themselves
hold the powerful accountable and save
lives in any disaster their mission is
to take the root causes of poverty and
create lasting solutions Oxfam's
approach is tackling the conditions that
cause poverty in the first place from
the information they gather they use it
for a saving lives
Oxfam assists the poorest communities
when disaster strikes
bu programs to overcome poverty and
injustice they help people assert their
rights so they can improve their lives
and see public education as part of the
efforts to overcome poverty Oxfam works
to change the way people think about
poverty and its causes if you look on
their site in their YouTube channel you
can not only see all the creative ways
and all the great people that help out
but you can see all the changes they're
being made with these people who so much
don't want to live in these conditions
anymore and you can play a huge part in
that this Christmas give the gift of
helping people be where they need to be
click on the link and see how you can
help the strong get even stronger
you